hi I'm Tim War II in cory hardrict and
today we are making our family stuffing
recipe this stuffing it's special to me
because it's a twist on the traditional
stuffing that I made with my mom while
growing up and what my mom would do is
she would throw oysters in the stuffing
and I wanted to do something different
you like the oyster stuffing done I like
the oyster I like the salty stuffing but
I like yours as well I love it all
so the first time I made this particular
recipe was last year and I was nervous
but I will say it was the one dish that
everyone was saying it was their
favorite in particular in particular my
brother what are you talking about mac
and cheese is their feet okay Cory see
it's like a competition with this one
the mac and cheese the family faith okay
I cook the macaroni and cheese she knows
it I like to use Italian sausage because
it comes already loaded with flavor
you have fennel seeds in there you have
chili pepper it's just delicious gotta
cook it through yes cook it through I
love a stuffing that sweet and savory so
the sausage makes it really nice and you
know savory and the Apple makes it nice
and sweet
this is definitely not your grandma's
boring stuffing grandma Stefan's not
cool sometimes it is sorry grandma the
trick to not making this soggy is you
don't want to pour the chicken broth on
top of the stuff and you just want to
take it along the edges of the baking
dish the most satisfying moment for me
it's not what I do is what other people
do when they eat the second if I see
that they have a huge smile on their
face then I feel like my job is done my
favorite part of the stuffing is eating
it and seeing all the family members
happy when I say Tia we loved your
stuffing you know we loved it that makes
me happy oh yes